okay from the internet Jack how do you
combat the strands of racism in the
Republican Party no Jack you used to be
what something the avenger there's an
Avenger the dixie controversy about that
right I've had to wrestle with my own
past and some things you know this Trump
phenomenon what bothered me the most is
I think it's true what Jeremy said
earlier there are people out there who
are openly bigots or hateful and
although I mean I don't think anybody
that says he might something that's
politically incorrect is necessarily
that as you've noted but there are a lot
of people out there who are straight-up
hateful they don't like minorities they
don't like gay people and I think Trump
and I don't think he intentionally did
this I think he's just being himself has
opened the floodgates honestly I don't
think he's that intentional I think he's
just being himself but I think people
who feel that way feel that they can
freely express those things in ways that
are not good for our society not good
for the country I think it's a problem
how do you combat it you'd be better
than that I'm a conservative on the
libertarian but I'm positive I look for
the best in individuals I don't group
people together I don't say you know
that's the worst thing you can do to
demonize human beings is to group them
together say these people are bad and
not judge them by their individual Worth
and human dignity a speech Michael Moore
good have given Michael would you
consider making a film on the media and
its influence on election results
somebody should make that film I don't
know if I'm the person to do it but I
you know actually I wanted to at the
beginning of this election season I was
going to kind of secretly film go on the
number of these shows not know your show
of course but other shows and just kind
of let show people what happens behind
the scenes how this comes together and I
was just talking to Scott your producer
that discussion between you and Jeremy
that took place you never see that on
the mainstream broadcast networks you
know where you guys really got into some
very serious you have a serious
disagreement wait wait
HBO is kind of a mainstream broadcaster
oh really you think so HBO I think I
don't hate to be how is mainstream at
all really yes have you seen Game of
Thrones
have you not you think that's mainstream
I think we're on a mainstream network I
don't think I do a mainstream show I
that's the difference but dying you know
right okay you're the father of dragons
look what I mean let me ask you a
broader question what do you think is
the future of documentaries cuz I mean
things have changed in the movie
business a lot to do started making them
I mean I don't know in this day and age
whether people they don't even I seem oh
I see most of my movies when I'm on the
road doing stand-up and then we get in
the hotel and they're like you know the
recently in theaters and they're like
sometimes they're like wow these are big
stars and it never even saw the light of
day in a theatre because the only movies
that seem to open now are about robots
punching each other well let me ask a
question back for you why haven't you
made more documentaries because that's
your thing I know
or film your one film is still one of
the top 50 s largest yes grossing
documentaries of all time because that
but I always said from that I said
before it I said after it I don't want
to be Michael Moore only he can do what
he does this is the one topic that I
wanted to tackle religion is stupid and
there's no God right you're gonna do
that right well you did a great job with
yeah but but but a we you and I want to
do it well well we shouldn't yes is this
is are we still alive on the internet
right now we're still alive if it
doesn't matter because we can't get this
thing going but you but the truth is
folks bill and I yeah we do have a
secret plan yeah we do and we've not
distrusted publicly and and we're not
going to at least our 2808 Minister I
know we want to do a movie called the
kings of atheism I thought okay there
it's out right reach out so well what
could like what's the worst that could
happen if we get it made most on that
one we're not no but you've just told
the almighty that we're gonna do this
and now we're not gonna you and I have
to survive the next six months
no I I love it remember the Kings of
Comedy the Kings of Comedy there was
like fright for cleaned african-american
correct and then they did the Latino
Kings yes for the kings of atheism Kings
the baby of Han we can't get anybody we
want to sign up we're going way we are
going to have four of America's yeah up
comedians I'm going to film it and we're
gonna travel through the Bible Belt
putting on movie show
I mean the first person I wanted to do
it was my fellow atheist and boyfriend
Seth MacFarlane I can't get him to
commit maybe you people could well we
can't get him to do it maybe they were
it's wouldn't if we got Ricky Gervais
right right aerosol sarah silverman and
others I said Eric Farland and I will
come out - yes you listen bill this is a
movement that you actually are
responsible to integrate you're the most
public person who for the last decade or
so has has been at the forefront of
questioning this and and you did it when
it was not popular when somebody at HBO
this mainstream network Ryan must have
said bill you know that's well ABC
before the ABC did edit rights Disney
well but now but now now please a great
thing what are you directing it is that
you're not an atheist that's great yes
well that's where the humor will come in
you know the ural come in in a lot of
place I will ride the bus with yes
comedians you and you're gonna buzz and
you'll have ten days right you'll have
10 days to convert me to your debauchery
basically so Oh everybody has to do is
contact Seth Ricky and Sarah and tell
them to do our movie and then right here
we're done and Ari get it get us the
money to do it alright Jeremy does
Edward Snowden seeking asylum in an
autocratic state like Russia damage his
credibility as a champion of human
rights
no well I mean the first problem with
that question is that's based on total
[ __ ] um Edward Edward Snowden was
seeking to go to Latin America and when
he was in route to Russia to then catch
a flight to Latin America the United
States canceled his passport and and he
still remains without a passport so he
didn't choose of course he's still in
Russia I chatted with him recently he
wrote the foreword to our book well I
mean I look I mean I don't friend joined
in there she did and she's got a girl
yes he has and his his same girlfriend
who was like under the sort of you know
full force of the national security
state initially because he didn't it
appears he
tell her anything about this before here
in Moscow fled the scene and yet and
they are some policies the mother I mean
there's no doubt I mean Russia is a is a
reprehensible human rights violating
sure autocratic society however Edward
Snowden I truly support him and believe
that his entire motive in doing this was
a just one and and that is rank
propaganda that's used against him to
imply he's somehow a treasonous ass
who's giving secrets to the FSB he the
Russian intelligence service he didn't
bring any documents there he didn't
choose Russia the United States chose
Russia and you know the question is did
they choose it knowing that that would
be the way that they could hammer him or
did they really believe that they were
going to somehow be able to snatch him
if he got on able morales his plane
which they forced a ground or another
nations aircraft well this question is
right in line with that have we
miscalculated how to deal with Russia
and its influence on the conflict in the
Middle East
oh yes I guess that's for anybody we
don't have to answer it yeah hey
internet ain't the boss of you've
stopped us Internet hmm you wind dinner
for two at Pepe's like stump the van but
with the panel bob is the lack of civic
education to blame for the state of
politics and discourse in this country
that's I think it's a significant fact
yeah they used to teach civics we
essentially stopped teaching civics
right states in the night even though
they even know how government works yeah
I don't one who should be in it frankly
Donald Trump didn't have much of a
background in civics
therefore he thinks that he's going to
be elected to be George the 3rd not the
president United States and would govern
like that uh
I think one of the most critical issues
to deal with the Trump's both personally
and their philosophy of government is to
reintroduce serious study of what it
means to be a citizen in a democracy
into our schools what are you some place
from which virtually vanish is it
totally gone it's gone and history and
largely s.r.o yet every school day still
begins in most schools with a pledge of
allegiance to the flag and then nothing
about what that means or what it stands
for or what we're supposed to be doing
about it and one of the things I
actually cut out of my film we went to
Austria Austria is one of a half a dozen
countries now they've lowered the voting
age to 16 because what they found is is
by getting kids to vote starting in high
school they bring candidates in they
bring the Registrar end they get them
going then and interested in it they've
now the statistics show they're 18 to 25
year olds vote at a higher percentage
than ours do in other countries where
the voting age is 18 like what they're
voting for in Austria is not
particularly appealing at the moment
they've just had a big far-right gains
in local elections Austria so whether in
Scotland Scotland the voting age was
lowered to 16 to allow 16 year-olds to
vote last year on whether or not
Scotland should remove its cell bank
from the UK we are not them I mean our
college kids are more like high school
kids 16 year olds are you kidding yeah
but we've got to have somewhere to make
them to us aspire to something you know
like we expect this and it's just it's
just like driver ed at 16 we should
start to learn about this process and be
involved in it and it's not just Bieber
it's not just the issue of lowering the
vote is a Canadian thinking there have
been aggressive efforts to keep the
current 18 to 21 year olds from voting
for instance in my state you can vote
early in a senior center in a library
every place except on a university
campus it's a very specific effort to
restrain sure and constrict the
participation and vote Republican
Attorney General in Michigan got a law
passed that prohibits students in
Michigan from voting on election day at
their college campus they have to leave
college that day and drive here at Ann
Arbor you live in Traverse City or Flint
or whatever you have to drive there on
Election Day or you have to figure out
how to get an absentee ballot a month
before that you can't vote where you're
going to school and they did that so
that they could again gerrymander out
thousands I mean in Michigan State
you've got fifty thousand students there
you know and yet Michigan State is
represented by Republican in Congress
because those fifty thousand students
couldn't vote in the place where they
live and go to school this is this goes
on all over the country it's never
written about or talked about and and
you're absolutely right Bob this is this
it's I think it's a big problem and you
add to that that that you have real
voter disenfranchisement that continues
violations of the Voting Rights Act in
African American communities and poor
communities I mean this is still rampant
you know I mean it's it's it really
there really is a sort of Jim Crow
racist element that continues on with
our elections I wonder if Senator Gramm
though would support a bill that said
that every Congress person has to wear
for their first day in office a suit
that has logos of the top fifty
corporations that funded their campaign
like NASCAR of course you've been ripped
off many times since oh you should look
at the Australian model where if you
don't vote you get a tax hit I mean it's
the only country in the world where
voting is effectively mandatory but do
we want people voting yeah why not
why shouldn't you go and if you don't
you're completely uninformed you go and
you spoil your ballot if you don't like
any of the options there you spoil your
ballot at least you've shown the Civic
there are too many countries in the
world that don't have the right to vote
if we have the right to vote we should
protect it and if that means giving
people you know that sixty percent of
all I have to do is get my ballot
there's nothing Prince's in America do
you know that's sixty percent of the
people in this country believe the
Noah's Ark story is literally true I
don't want them voting then we need more
education
yeah and here we got to go yeah bless
50% you very much everybody